[Música]
pues vamos ahora con nuestro siguiente
invitado del día y el tema que nos acoge
en este momento ese tiktok y de la
manera en que se accede a esta red
social la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos
en Kevin mccarthy el representante dijo
que los legisladores avanzarán con la
legislación o sobre preocupaciones de
seguridad nacional alegando que el
gobierno de China tuvo acceso a los
datos de usuarios a través de esta
aplicación en el país hay cada vez más
llamados a prohibirla y porque es
propiedad además de la empresa by Dance
con sede en China en Japón por lo tanto
avanza también una medida similar
después es de que varios gobiernos la
limitaran en sus dispositivos
gubernamentales y parlamentarios vamos a
conversar sobre el uso y la adicción que
genera tiktoko con Manuel Herrera quien
es analista internacional docente e
investigador de la facultad de finanzas
gobierno y relaciones internacionales de
la Universidad externado de Colombia
también magíster en ciencia política de
la Universidad Católica de lobaina
Bélgica Muchas gracias Manuel por estar
en directo a América usted Muchísimas
gracias Pues comienzo preguntándole se
puede decir que los gobiernos están
aplicando un boicot contra tiktok Y por
qué Sí en efecto esta situación que
estamos viendo con tiktok y hay que
enmarcarla en una competencia a un nivel
superior sin un resultado Claro entre
Estados Unidos y China y eso pues se
representa en que Estados Unidos está
buscando limitar las acciones de China
pero que Creo yo que está perjudicando
en últimas también esas premisas que
Estados Unidos históricamente han
defendido que es la libertad la
competencia entre empresas y digamos que
los argumentos que se han esgrimido en
el congreso de la República Pues de
Estados Unidos realmente no son
suficientemente fuertes en la medida que
dice que no que tiktok tiene unas
afectaciones sobre los niños pero
digamos que si uno hace un juicio o hace
un ejercicio juicioso pues evidencia que
también Instagram por ejemplo Facebook
entre otras aplicaciones También tienen
una repercusiones frente a la salud de
los jóvenes porque también generan
depresión a esto pues se agrega que el
representante de tiktok en el congreso
mencionaba que los datos de esta empresa
pues está utilizando o la están
ejecutando o manipulando una compañía
que se llama Oracle para darle
tranquilidad también a Estados Unidos y
sus aliados con este propósito entonces
creo que los argumentos que Estados
Unidos ha esgrimido para limitar el
accionar de esta aplicación en Estados
Unidos no siguen siendo fuertes No son
suficientes y que creo que está Abriendo
puertas que creo que no le convendría a
la democracia ni tampoco a las a la
sociedad civil Bueno una cosa es la toma
de datos de los usuarios
supuestamente para activar más
influencia del lado de China Pero por
otro lado Usted cree que bastaría por
ejemplo con aplicar un control parental
para solucionar el tema de la exposición
que tienen los jóvenes y los niños a
tiktok en Francia ya hay una ley en
curso para que se haga este control
parental creo que desde los 15 o 16 años
aproximadamente y en
uno de los estados de Estados Unidos ya
se aprobó una restricción hasta los 18
años Usted qué opina sí creo que eso
podría ser una solución de hecho también
en China hay unas ciertas restricciones
para que menores utilicen los celulares
puede ser una excelente opción pero sin
embargo también a eso hay que hay que
también ser sinceros Y es que también
queda espacios también para que no hay
una 100% de verificación de que
realmente tenga la edad correspondiente
para el uso pero creo que puede ser una
una muy buena medida para la restricción
y el control frente a eso Ahora hay un
tema que son tres temas claves en frente
a tiktok del problema el primero es que
tiene un algoritmo que permite digamos
que la secuencia rápida y Pues digamos
que es lo que pues muchos congresistas
dicen que es peligroso no el segundo es
un algoritmo de perfilamiento de la
persona y el tercero es el de
clasificación también de ese gusto del
usuario y el de perfilamiento Pero
entonces Creo yo que aquí el debate
tiene que ir mucho más amplio y creo que
aquí también tenemos que traer sobre la
mesa la discusión sobre la política de
la gobernanza de la porque esta
situación Estos algoritmos no son
solamente de tiktok también le podemos
verlo en otras aplicaciones de Instagram
que también generan dependencia Entonces
quiero yo que este debate si deberíamos
sentarlo de manera sensata entre todas
las aplicaciones porque no hay que
olvidar que por ejemplo La regulación de
datos de la comisión Europea de Europa y
también como la comisión de consumidor
australiano también han puesto en tela
de juicio las acciones de Facebook
Instagram y WhatsApp también entonces
quiero yo que esto es una invitación
abrir un debate mucho más amplio y no
solamente contra una compañía sino que
miremos Cómo podemos aparte de la de la
regla de la norte de la edad buscar otro
tipo de mecanismos y herramientas para
poder también limitar por ejemplo y con
esto terminaría es la gran pregunta
sería los algoritmos deberían de ser
desarrollados o tener una influencia del
Estado el Mercado o la sociedad civil y
creo que esa es la gran pregunta a
resolver de aquí en adelante sin embargo
lo que usted nos plantea pues es un
debate entre usuarios no entre como yo
sí soy mamá debo controlar el acceso de
menor de edad a las redes sociales o
como yo como usuario responsable debo
limitar mi tiempo conectado a redes que
No necesariamente solo son tiktok Pero
por otro lado está la parte
gubernamental la parte regulatoria
recientemente el tiktok lo decíamos al
inicio pues se tuvo que declarar ante el
congreso dio estas declaraciones que
usted nos recordaba sobre la
preocupación por el robo de los datos de
los usuarios
y además sabemos que Estados Unidos
Busca hacer que tiktok venda su
participación en el país se cosa a la
que se niega a la compañía China antes
de eso el uso en los dispositivos o
gubernamentales y parlamentarios fue
prohibido en varios países de Nueva
Zelanda Canadá por ahí están mencionados
porque el ataque directo en este momento
contra tiktok y no contra Facebook o
Instagram o Bueno cualquier cantidad de
aplicaciones que existen en el mercado y
es un excelente pregunta Digamos si en
relación con el uso de la preocupación
de las mamás de hecho tiktok también
tiene herramientas para limitar cierto
tiempo el uso de esa aplicación digamos
que eso también sería otra herramienta
pero Creo yo que el enfoque aquí
principal es el que usted le da y es en
el sentido que estamos en una
competencia y Creo yo que Estados Unidos
utiliza estos argumentos por ejemplo de
la salud de los niños y otras cosas pero
para no sé si ocultar pero sí para
distraer el debate Y es que claramente
aquí silicon Valley perdió ese
oligopolio que había gozado durante Las
dos últimas dos décadas y Que obviamente
ve amenazado que lleguen nuevas
plataformas que puedan serle competencia
y no hay que olvidar una cosa mientras
que se desarrollaba ese debate en el
congreso por ejemplo mientras que
Facebook e Instagram tenían una ganancia
en bolsa de 4.4 y 3.4 por ciento
respectivamente ticto caía en las
finanzas entonces también tiene un doble
daño también una doble doble objetivo
que también es económico pero aquí aquí
yo creo que hay otro tema clave que que
es de Resaltar y Es que creo que Estados
Unidos y los países se evidencian que
estas aplicaciones se convierten en
insumos estratégicos para la
inteligencia y la contrainteligencia y
creo que realmente Más allá de la salud
de los menores y los jóvenes que
claramente puede preocuparles creo que
hay con otro tema que ese tema de
seguridad nacional y que Considero que
claramente cada país está buscando
proteger esos datos con el propósito de
que otro país No los utilice en el marco
de un orden mundial que desde mi lectura
está contestado donde hay potencias
emergentes donde hay países que ya no
quieren más el liderazgo de Estados
Unidos y occidente y que claramente se
han dado cuenta que la parte digital
tiene tres factores súper importantes el
primero de ellos es el económico los
e-commerce no también estas aplicaciones
generan mucha economía para los países
el segundo factor es un factor político
que es quien va a condensar quién va a
manejar todos estos datos que se puedan
recolectar de esas aplicaciones y el
tercer punto y no menos importante se
han dado cuenta los estados que a través
de estas aplicaciones se pueden infundir
ideas hashtag no como estos elementos
que pueden organizar y ser digamos
dominar o organizar de cierta manera la
opinión pública de ciertos países y no
hay que olvidar el caso de Cambridge
analítica con Facebook en las elecciones
del 2016 con el presidente Trump Y eso
es un claro ejemplo de que Cuál es el
poder que pueden tener estas compañías
con estos datos Bueno pero también hay
que pensar en cómo nos están vendiendo
el discurso no porque una cosa es el
temor por el robo de nuestros datos de
lo cual Somos responsables como usuarios
y libres de Descargar o no las
aplicaciones pero le quiero poner El
ejemplo de WhatsApp para cuando fue
prohibido en China que fue un discurso
en el sentido de la libertad de
expresión no cómo se estaba guardando en
China la libertad de expresión la
libertad de comunicación Cómo se estaba
limitando la comunicación de los
usuarios a través Pues de la prohibición
de WhatsApp pero aquí cuando se está
planteando la prohibición de tiktok de
lo que se está hablando desde un asunto
de seguridad se pone a un nivel mucho
más alto y mucho más preocupante pues
que genera una conversación amplia no
solo en Estados Unidos sino en todo
occidente No sí en efecto los estados
buscan a través de sus relatos
configurar también y justificar sus
acciones en política exterior y eso ese
ejemplo Que usted da es muy acertado y
tampoco hay que olvidar que por ejemplo
china también restringió Uber en su en
su por también este tipo de aplicaciones
que podían sacar información entonces
quiero que claramente todos los países
tenemos que aquí no solamente Estados
Unidos frente a China sino también
debemos que china hacia occidente tiene
una cierta restricciones por ejemplo
Google tampoco YouTube no tienen Google
como esta plataforma de buscador
Entonces quiero yo que claramente
comparto Esa visión digamos quiero que
Estados Unidos para distraer la
discusión de fondo que es una
competencia que es una rivalidad que
también el asistente de tiktok es una
muestra de que ese liderazgo y hegemonía
Que gusto Estados Unidos en materia de
tecnológico pues ya hoy está haciendo
competida por su gran rival que ha sido
china no Entonces quiero yo que también
hay detrás de eso o tratar de distraer
la discusión pero que es una muestra de
esa competencia y en que Estados Unidos
no quiere salirse de ese liderazgo ahora
a mí lo que me preocupa de estas
discusiones como decía anteriormente que
la discusión Tiene que hablar sobre la
política de la gobernanza la información
es otro tema es que si un estado y se le
aprueba que pueda limitar una aplicación
que la cierren que la obliguen a comprar
pues no solamente rompe esa premisa de
libre comercio y la competencia sino que
también también abriría el camino para
que cualquier estado una aplicación que
no le guste que no le convenga al
gobierno le de potestad para cerrarlo Y
creo que eso es delicado y más en estos
tiempos donde estamos en un mundo no
solamente en el escenario internacional
contestado sino también evidenciamos que
en los diferentes países del mundo sin
importar su nivel de riqueza hay un
cierto inconformismo hacia las élites
políticas y que creo que eso podría
afectar el cierre este tipo de
aplicaciones bueno y en otro tema algo
que también es muy preocupante es cómo
pueden operar las redes sociales tiktok
incluida y posiblemente en primer lugar
absolutamente sin ningún control no más
que el propio control que ellos dicen
que están ejerciendo sobre los
contenidos que tanto le interesa a
tiktok que realmente controlar sus
contenidos y le pongo un ejemplo y es
una tendencia que se está poniendo muy
de moda más hacia Europa en Italia y en
el Reino Unido Y es que los jóvenes se
pellizcan
la mejilla hasta que se hacen una herida
hasta que se dejan una cicatriz Y esta
es una tendencia de tiktok que la están
empezando a detectar han habido ya
denuncias de parte de por ejemplo del
gobierno italiano pues contestando a
tiktok Por qué no retira estos
contenidos Y por qué no lleva a cabo las
acciones legales correspondientes tiktok
dice que sí que lo está ejerciendo que
hay más de 40.000 digamos empleados
encargados de verificar la seguridad en
la red social sin embargo eso No evita
que tendencias como esta y otras
muchísimo más dañinas se extiendan a lo
largo de la red y se vuelvan incluso
mundiales sí creo que aquí es una
corresponsabilidad de todos los actores
y yo también quiero que sí claramente
las aplicaciones sea tiktok o la que sea
tiene que tener unas políticas que
también
propenden por el bienestar del usuario
también quiero que otra
corresponsabilidades del estado y no
solamente el estado de limitar estas
compañías sino también como lo
mencionaba anteriormente un tema
importantísimo que Francia lo ha hecho y
en mi opinión lo ha hecho muy bien es
también el pago de impuestos de estas
compañías pero también una correspon
también tiene que ser del usuario Aquí
traigo a colación lo que nos decía Carl
saga en este gran físico en sus en sus
programas que nos mencionaba el problema
no es el avance de la tecnología
realmente el problema es la manera como
los los usuarios no comprenden no sabe
cómo funciona no saben un porqué de eso
ni un para qué y yo creo que aquí
también la invitación es para nosotros
los usuarios que les entregamos de
manera libre y Autónoma los datos es
también cuestionarnos hacer también ese
ejercicio democrático decir esto de
quién es para quién es y por qué Y
también hacer un consumo mucho más
responsable eso no quiere decir que el
estado y las compañías también eliminen
su responsabilidad claramente tienen que
tener una corresponsabilidad en el
ejercicio de aplicación en esto en las
en todas las esferas económica política
y social Pero creo yo que aquí también
es un mensaje claro para los usuarios y
obviamente para los adultos Ya pues
mayores con sus hijos en relación con
estas aplicaciones entonces No podemos
dejarle Solo esa tarea a unos pocos si
no podemos ser presos como consumidores
Muchas gracias Manuel analista
internacional y docente de la
Universidad externado de Colombia por
una conversación muy amena que tenga
buen día
y a nuestros televidentes de directo
América sigan con nosotros ya volvemos
con más
[Música]